it's one of Mother Nature's miracles
[Music]
the unbreakable bond between a mom and
her baby
by the time newborn animals are running
around bedazzling us with their cuteness
[Music]
they've already survived an incredibly
long turbulent Journey
as mom's Precious Cargo
an ordeal never seemed quite like this
until now
[Music]
this is a story about four magnificent
mamas
and their little bundles of joy
[Music]
Brumby a working girl who lives for the
nine to five
[Music]
bisa a rookie matriarch learning the
ropes as she leads Her Herd
Swift Alpha of a meerkat Clan
fighting the odds in her hostile home
and Maya a proud Hunter who will go to
extraordinary lengths to ensure her Cubs
survival
[Music]
now Cutting Edge scanning technology
and computer animation are giving us the
most realistic picture ever
life inside the womb
[Music]
brought to you in super baby vision
witness life before birth
Greatest Adventure of all
[Music]
foreign
Savannah
[Music]
and it is hot
this pride of proud sisters cools their
heels
waiting for the less sweltering evening
before going on the prowl
thank you
[Music]
but one lioness
has chosen not to hang with her
girlfriends
Maya
[Music]
this six-year-old Hunter is taking her
chances on a solo mission
[Music]
she hasn't eaten for three days
and her swollen belly is a Telltale sign
that she's not the only one who's hungry
Maya has four Cubs along for the ride
this is kasuba in Prime position
siblings are just five weeks into their
16-week roller coaster ride to life
when you need to eat for five
Buffalo really hits the spot
just one of these could keep her and her
Cubs going for a week
this is no snooze cruise for her babes
it's a bumpy ride
[Music]
fortunately they're safely stowed in
sacks attached to the
at both ends
their very own baby hammocks
[Music]
but today this famished feline is
pushing The Hammocks to the Limit
they're holding for now
though might not withstand those nasty
horns
remember
[Music]
Maya is beat
with nothing to show for her efforts
[Music]
and oh that's not good
he's gotten herself and her little ones
boxed in
[Music]
the Colorado plains
Brumby country
for this five-year-old Australian
Shepherd
home is frying pan Ranch
thousands of Acres of some of the best
grazing in North America
trying to race us
working dog Brumby will soon have a
whole new herd to Wrangle
a brand new litter of puppies
it starts out the same way it does for
all mammal mamas
[Music]
a few lucky fertilized eggs
swished Along by tiny hair-like cells
and muscle contractions
race for the top spot in the womb
[Music]
this one has bagged Pole Position
here Mom's blood supply will give it
everything it needs
[Music]
feed Neiman over here bringing up the
rear is a straggler
implanting furthest from the main
nutritious blood supply this one will
turn out smaller and weaker
and end up being the runt of the litter
sorry pal
let's go
[Music]
Laura and James aren't just brumby's
family they're her co-workers
[Music]
herding cattle together since Brumby was
a pup
[Music]
s
farm work is a round-the-clock job
[Music]
but it's not all plain sailing dogs even
tough cowgirls get morning sickness just
like we do
foreign
the experts aren't really sure why it
happens at all
but Brumby is the only one of our Uber
moms that shows the signs of this
miserable side effect
[Music]
Chen up Brumby you'll be back on the
ranch in no time
[Music]
first light in South Africa's Kalahari
Desert
a hostile scrub land
with scarce and venomous resources
life here is no picnic
this is Swift meerkat Warrior Queen
and boss mom of 14 adults
and four baby kids
the whiskers Clan
round these parts only Swift gets to
play Ma
it's her way or the highway
any other female who gets pregnant is
scent packing
[Music]
litters
and now number 12 is on the way
only 1 16 of an inch long princess is
three weeks into her 11-week journey
time for her very first heartbeat
the whisker spends most of their day
digging for gold
edible gold that is
but this puts them out in the open
exposed to predators
a sentinel Rings the alarm
a cape cobra
one bite can kill
[Music]
Fearless clean Swift rallies her troops
they may be small but there's a lot of
them
thank you
closing in on the enemy Swift and her
clan deploys some cunning scare tactics
[Music]
the Cobra has poor eyesight
lined up shoulder to shoulder
the clan looks like one single ferocious
adversary
foreign
[Music]
together the mob has sent the snake
packing
but at what cost
[Music]
their Queen is down
and the Kalahari Desert
pregnant meerkat Swift has been taken
down by a snake
her blood pulses with Cobra Venom
Princess and the kids twitch
they can sense mom's pain
a cobra bite could kill a human in
minutes
but this Mama's got a superpower
her body contains natural Anti-Venom
as Swift shakes it off her babies relax
[Music]
princess and her siblings have survived
and Swift is back on her throne
[Music]
but it's a handy FYI that out here even
the most experienced mom needs to keep
on her toes
in the burning heat of the Zambian
Savannah
hundreds of Buffalo
and a single lioness
are facing off
Maya's solo hunting Mission has gotten
her
and her babies
in a jam
all right
laughs
[Music]
hold up
looks like Maya's not alone anymore
The Sisterhood United are not a group to
be messed with
the strength of a lion lies in her Pride
[Music]
the next generation of the family kasuba
and his three siblings are safe
[Music]
but those babies
they still need feeding
their hungry mama will have to hunt
again soon
[Music]
thank you
Visa is the boss lady of this little
herd of elephants
[Music]
don't be fooled by the wrinkles she's
only just turned 18.
after her mother the old matriarch
passed she inherited this ragtag bunch
all right
[Music]
there's a couple of tween boys
they'll need watching
three younger sisters learning how to
elephant
and an orphaned baby
[Music]
whose goal in life is to become the
muddiest elephant in all of Kenya
[Music]
but he's not going to be the youngest
for much longer
pregnant for the first time
her calf TAMU is four months into a
22-month pregnancy Marathon
[Music]
he's only two inches long
at Birth
he'll have grown to three feet and
weighed 250 pounds
today tamus got a brand new toy
foreign
fires a signal
this is the very first time he can
control his trunk
now he just has to figure out what to do
with it
got another 18 months to puzzle that out
and it's a good thing Visa has 18 months
to prepare for his arrival
young elephants usually have older
females help them give birth
so she needs to find some older
girlfriends before the big day comes
meanwhile mom is learning the ropes as
herd head honcho and will lead them far
and wide to find the mammoth amounts of
food and water they need to survive
[Music]
by the time TAMU is born Visa will have
led her gang more than 3 000 miles
[Music]
let's hope she can also find some
elephant midwives along the way
[Music]
for now play time is over
Open Road
[Music]
our four moms-to-be are now about a
third of the way through their
pregnancies
[Music]
tiny eyes
and sparking brains and their hearts are
beating Softly
[Music]
they have passed the early riskiest
stage of pregnancy
now
starts to get bigger
and you know what they say
[Music]
bigger kids
bigger problems
[Music]
it's late afternoon in the Kalahari
dinner time
surprise surprise the clan is enjoying
takeout again
[Music]
Swift is now six weeks along
and like most pregnant moms when she's
hungry she's not happy
[Music]
today the desert's just not playing ball
oh this is a sad excuse for foraging
[Music]
her four little tummy tots are counting
on her for leftovers
they are three quarters of an inch long
and each has their own placenta their
connection to Mom's blood supply
Swift will have to eat around 20 percent
more to keep her kids well fed
[Music]
but she still hasn't managed to score
big today
[Music]
foreign
to check out the menu options down the
road
but dining alone is risky
and the weather is turning
the whiskers Dash back to the safety of
their home Borough
except for Swift
now too far to return
she heads to another makeshift shelter
just in time
she's safe Underground
but the dust storm blocks the tunnel
entrance
trapping the hungry mama and her
precious kids
no chance of dinner for anyone tonight
[Music]
hours slip by
running dangerously low on energy
Swift's body does something amazing
she reduces the blood supply to her kids
keeping more for herself
and buying some extra survival time
[Music]
foreign
they have their own superpower
temporary hibernation
but they can't hold out for long
Swift will need a new plan
[Music]
waking up at the home Borough the
whiskers have no clue where their leader
is
[Music]
last night's storm has made it harder to
pick up her scent
[Music]
after missing dinner last night Swift's
running on stored energy and willpower
everybody is down to their very last
Reserves
with no sign of a rescue mission the
warrior Queen starts doing it for
herself
foreign
[Music]
now she needs to find a speedy breakfast
good morning millipede
[Music]
fast food just what the doctor ordered
nutrients flow into her kits
waking princess and her siblings from
their deep sleep
[Music]
time to go home
underground or overground
Savvy matriarch has proved she has what
it takes to keep her babies alive
[Music]
early morning on frying pan Ranch
y has sailed through four weeks of
pregnancy
she's over the morning sickness blues
and back in the saddle
[Music]
which is convenient because this working
mom-to-be and her human co-workers have
to drive the herd 10 miles today
the commute is no sweat for Brumby
she is built to run
foreign
even with a tummy full of puffs
[Music]
right now her bouncing babies are
doubling in size every week
to feed them Brumby is making 20 more
blood
and this super mom on the Run grabs
twice as much oxygen from the air as
other animals her size
the girl is not slacking
but this is a tough gig
a knit to the left
a bark to the right
[Music]
the pups are feeling the burn too
far end of the womb the runt gets less
food and oxygen than the rest
your heart is beating extra fast
foreign
[Music]
the final pinch point
Brumby must guide these giant muing
machines into the Corral
[Music]
there's always one
typical
[Music]
probably get back
Cattle Dog Brumby has taken a serious
kick from one of her cows
Laura who's also a veterinarian must
check her out
[Music]
it's also a chance to find out how many
passengers are on board okay
okay here's one
two
three
four
probably look there you go
looks pretty healthy
four beating hearts
it's only a small litter but thankfully
all the pups are safe inside sacks
acting like their own personal airbags
they're developing fast
and they are now big enough for Laura to
see those all important details
three big girls
and at the far end of the womb
the runts of the litter
small but proving Mighty it's Daisy
[Music]
good job good Mama for now Brumby can
rest easy knowing all is well
though she may want to cut back a little
on the hoof chasing
you're a good Mama
damn right she is
in Kenya it's been a year since 18 year
old bisa Took the Wheel as heard leader
and the rookie has been flying high
this kind of greenery is elephant heaven
everybody is making the most of a bit of
downtime
[Music]
smallest members are busy trying to make
new friends
whether they like it or not
[Music]
teen mom-to-be Visa is now nearly
halfway through her pregnancy
on board for almost a year
he's already as heavy as a newborn human
baby
[Music]
tamu's feeling the chill out Vibe too
mainlining mom's happy hormones through
his umbilical cord
but recess is over
when it rains here sister it rains
[Music]
and this area could flood
time to move on
[Music]
this shower doesn't last long
but it's rainy season and River levels
are high
for a newbie leader the trick is knowing
where to cross
[Music]
this could work
so far so good
but the deeper water is a big ask for
the youngest
uh oh
lucky everyone's got their own snorkel
it's elephant chaos
[Music]
even tamu's getting thrown around
Visa does her best to encourage the Gang
[Music]
TAMU can actually hear his mother's
trumpeting through the fluid in the womb
it's the first time he can make out her
voice
for Comfort he sucks his trunk just like
a baby sucks its thumb
they're almost to the other side but the
currents picked up
she's lost one
[Music]
foreign
steer the little calf back to shore
[Music]
they've made it
even if it was a bit of a nightmare
[Music]
with the vibe now more chill
the family dig into a well-earned salad
bar
TAMU stops sucking his trunk
snuggles against mom
and visas rewarded by feeling her baby's
touch for the first time
[Music]
our amazing Mamas are all about halfway
through their pregnancies
[Music]
and their babies are starting to look
like recognizable many moms
[Music]
the Midway point is five weeks for
Brumby
and her pups are just starting to get
very active
halfway is nearly a year for Tamu
mom and son are forming an unbreakable
Bond
long before birth
[Music]
nearly nine weeks along Maya's little
Hunters have the beginnings of their
survival tool kits
kasuba's claws are forming one day they
will be deadly weapons an inch and a
half long
[Music]
Swift super kits are six weeks into
their Journey
[Music]
mom's womb may feel spacious now but her
babies will grow about four times larger
in the next five weeks
[Music]
they've all come a long way
but the most exciting part of the
journey
still lies ahead
because now
moms and babies are rushing headlong to
the finish line
to birth
[Music]